et sans détour benoît hamon répond ce
soir à nos questions bonsoir vous êtes
porte parole du parti socialiste mais
duquel le sun le seul qui existe
celui qui a dirigé par françois hollande
vous disiez ya encore quelques minutes
on va mal qu'est ce que ça veut dire
jusqu'à quel point le parti socialiste
va mal
non on va mal quand on cesse d'être un
parti laïc un parti qui idolâtrent une
candidate ou un parti qui pensent qu'il
faut faire du tout sauf ségolène pour
s'en sortir je pense qu'il faut re deux
micros redevienne partis laïcs qui se
préoccupe des problèmes des français
avant de se préoccuper lui-même et
ségolène royal qui citent la bible elle
fait toujours partie d'un parti laïc je
pense pas que ce soit aujourd'hui la
bonne référence pour nous en sortir
réunis pour la première fois ce soir
depuis début 2006 je crois neuf partis
de gauche vous y étiez d'ailleurs dont
le parti socialiste le pcf les verts et
la lcr c'était tout à l'heure vous êtes
mis d'accord sur une déclaration commune
qui condamne la politique de nicolas
sarkozy vous pouvez préciser le moment
est grave
nicolas sarkozy y ait décidé de
s'attaquer
au modèle social français la note va
être salée il faudra cotiser plus
longtemps pour partir à la retraite sans
doute pour être obligés de contracter
une retraite complémentaire il faudra
payer les franchises santé sans doute
est en situation d'avoir une bonne
complémentaire pour pouvoir être
remboursés contre la maladie
la période d'essai sera plus longue les
conditions dans lesquelles l'employeur
pourra se séparer de vous seront
beaucoup plus facile qu'auparavant
la note va être salée et ceux et celles
qui déjà sur leur pouvoir d'achat paye
au prix fort ce qu'ont été les 14
milliards de cadeaux fiscaux
souvenons-nous ans qui ont été faits aux
plus aisés et bien voit aujourd'hui
leurs conditions de départ la retraite
leur condition pour se protéger de la
maladie
leurs conditions les conditions dans
lesquelles ils vont pouvoir travailler
c'est à dire ce qui est
cette précarité croissante cette
vulnérabilité croissante et bien tous à
s'aggraver et c'est pour ça qu'il était
nécessaire que la gauche unie 10 dès ce
soir à nicolas sarkozy qu'elle
s'opposera à ce projet de démantèlement
du modèle social français vous
manifesterez les 29 septembre prochain
événement s'effondre c'est une
manifestation qui est prévue depuis très
longtemps entre les franchises médicales
que les français oui les socialistes
avaient déjà deux prévus depuis
longtemps d'y être pourquoi parce que
tous les français désormais chaque fois
qu'ils devront consommer des médicaments
ou aller devant le médecin ils paieront
une franchise c'est à dire que sur une
part de leurs dépenses ils ne seront pas
remboursés
moi je trouve assez curieux aujourd'hui
que celles et ceux qu'ils soient mis à
contribution se soient tous les français
quand par ailleurs les stock options
dont on dit que ce sont des revenus du
travail ne sont pas mis à contribution
quand par ailleurs on ne parle pas de la
retraite des grands patrons de ces
retraites différer de ces stock options
ou ses golden parachute toutes choses
qui ne sont pas mises à contribution
pour financer la sécurité sociale quand
aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy appelle tous
les français à la solidarité et au fait
qu'il fasse des efforts supplémentaires
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui je voudrais
qu'on en prenne la mesure c'est que nous
sommes en train de normaliser la france
et de l'aligner sur quoi les états unis
et l'angleterre sarkozy c'est reagan
plus thatcher les conséquences tous les
français vont les payer
dès cet automne alors